on consacre en moyenne et gsb en moyenne
deux heures et demie par jour à son
téléphone intelligent ça c'est 38 jours
par année
c'est six ans et demi d'une vie adulte
ok on utilise des téléphones
intelligents pour toutes sortes
d'excellentes raisons la preuve vous est
peut-être en train de nous regarder sur
votre cellulaire et c'est très bien
comme ça n'empêche on commence à peine à
mesurer l'impact de cette technologie la
sur nos cerveaux et sur nos rapports
avec les autres et est ce que démontrent
les récentes études scientifiques
c'est que l'utilisation abusive peut
créer une dépendance changer le
fonctionnement de notre cerveau
on se fit tellement notre cellulaire
qu'il peut réduire nos capacités
cognitives votre quotient intellectuel
il peut réduire notre capacité à se
concentrer provoqué de l'anxiété de la
solitude affecté notre posture notre
respiration et même affecté la qualité
de notre sommeil
au québec la compagnie orageuse a mené
un sondage et deux personnes sur trois
avoue se sentir démuni lorsqu'elles sont
déconnectés dans les cas les plus
extrêmes certains chercheurs parlent de
phobies lan homophobie pour nos montbard
phobia la peur de ne pas avoir son
cellulaire
c'est vous que plusieurs personnalités
influent de la silicon valley qui
préfèrent aujourd'hui tourner le dos à
ce genre de technologie qu'ils ont
pourtant aidé à créer par exemple
justin rose anne sting l'inventeur du
bouton j'aime sur facebook
eh ben il dit aujourd'hui regretter
d'avoir inventé parce que selon lui ce
genre d'information fait en sorte que
tout le monde est distrait tout le temps
aujourd'hui les enfants vient au monde
avec ses appareils dans leur
environnement
les pédiatres canadiens disent que la
technologie évolue tellement vite que
c'est difficile de mesurer l'impact sur
le développement des jeunes enfants
c'est pour cela que les médecins
recommandent aux parents de limiter le
temps d'écran et surtout surtout donner
l'exemple aux enfants